il aime on va parler de la crise
sanitaire et des masques ffp2 puisque la
question de leur utilisation se pose et
belin payan le maire de marseille a
annoncé qu'il allait en distribuer des
milliers
oui c'est clairement le sujet qui anime
les débats dans le corps enseignant le
corps enseignant qui sera mobilisé on le
sait de même massivement en france et
notamment à marseille où les fédérations
de parents d'élèves c'est une première
et bien se joindront à la mobilisation
dans leur ensemble dans leur intégralité
et donc benoît payant et bien a décidé
d'aller au delà des mesures sanitaires
présenté par jean castex développé par
jean michel blanquer roues il y aura
bien de distribution pour l'ensemble des
enseignants mais aussi des personnels
éducatifs de ces fameux masques ffp2
réputé bien plus sécurisant pour les
personnes qui les portent au moment où
dans les bouches du rhône le taux
d'incidence a dépassé les 1600 et où
forcément le virus du coc vide circule
très largement merci beaucoup merci
guilhem d'avoir été avec nous pendant
parler de cette actualité riche du côté
de marseille on regarde la une de la
provence aujourd'hui à l'eau le 15 c'est
la question à la une de la provence
puisqu'avec mais la crise sanitaire est
évidemment la provence se plonge dans
les coulisses du samu des bouches du
rhône merci beaucoup merci guilhem rica
vie d'avoir été avec noé a très vite un
mot sur cette dernière information
venant peillon qui a donc décidé de
distribuer 100 mille masques ffp2 est ce
que comme depuis le début de la crise on
est sur ce sujet qui est un nouveau
sujet qui monte avec des élus locaux qui
sont finalement peut-être en avance sur
gouvernement oui au
pouce et il a oui je crois
la raison le virus circule et arrêtons
de dramatiser alex est bon benoît payant
il fait ce qu'il veut dans sa commune et
dans sa ville
c'est après tout une mesure de sécurité
qui ne peut être que ça lui s'il en a
les moyens et s'il estime que c'est
nécessaire mais dire par là que
maintenant je crois qu'on sait à peu
près et quel est le profil de ce variant
au micro on sait qu'il est très
contagieux et on sait aussi qu'il est
beaucoup moins pathogène donc laissons
le circuler plutôt que de couper les
cheveux en quatre finalement on n'y
comprend plus rien du tout mais partons
sur ces données là et ce qui est sûr
c'est que omicron reste très dangereux
pour les personnes qui sont en état de
co qui ont des comorbidités ou qui sont
des personnes âgées pour le reste on va
sinon on y est encore dans un siècle
oui alors c'est vrai que pour les
enseignants avoir un ffp2 c'est une
c'est une revendication qui me semble
absolument légitime c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes exposés toute la journée avec
des enfants et bien à une potentielle
contamination vous avez des pays j'étais
calluyer quelques temps république
tchèque qui impose le ffp2 partout donc
l'idée que grosso modo ce serait un
objet totalement exceptionnel ça
m'apparaît ne pas être aujourd'hui une
réalité en revanche délégué ça aux
collectivités c'est problématique parce
que peut-être que la mairie de marseille
en a les moyens en revanche une petite
commune au fin fond du puy de dome ou au
fin fond du jura elle n'aura peut-être
pas les moyens de fournir des faits de
tous ces enseignants les inégalités
territoriales importante là pour le coup
même si c'est une compétence normalement
des collectivités territoriales régions
départements ou communes selon le niveau
scolaire c'est quand même plutôt quelque
chose qui doit être assumé par l'état et
un mot sur cette question a parlé
évidemment du passé actional et on
parlait des enseignants est ce que vous
la comprenez cette colère des
enseignants qui vous mobiliser
massivement demain face à des protocoles
domaine
des transports publics et après après
demain ça sera les agents des impôts et
après après demain ça sera le personnel
pénitentiaire écoutez on est
certainement pas je pense que c'est
effectivement compliqué je pense qu'il
ya eu des cafouillages dans
l'organisation du dispositif scolaire
antico vide et on voit que le ministre
de l'éducation s'était peut-être pas sa
priorité des priorités pour serrer c'est
un public aussi qui n'est pas explosé je
suis désolé faut arrêter de dire
n'importe quoi aussi ceux qui meurent de
cette histoire là et qui ont des graves
conséquences
ce sont des personnes très particulière
ce sont des personnes très si la moyenne
de la mortalité et je crois des gens qui
ont sont décédés du code de la coved
c'est des gens qui ont 82 83 ans donc
après acceptons notre sort et faisons en
sorte que ça se passe le moins mal
possible mais vient les enseignants ils
prennent aussi prétexte d'un système
de cette histoire pour pour un jt c'est
uniquement un prétexte je vois la
circulation des assurances et services
aux parents qui ont déjà plein de choses
à gérer en raison de ce colis de leur
vie professionnelle et de leur
rendre service aux parents présents
c'est les îles sont pas là pour rendre
service à l'un pour éduquer les employés
mais l'ensemble des fédérations de
parents d'élèves ici sont raccord avec
aisance avions d'affaires à dire que ben
a visiblement si c'est à dire que on a
pour le coup tous les poulets de toutes
les fédérations de parents d'élèves qui
disent qu'en effet pour le coup cette
grève est justifiée parce que vous avez
des dysfonctionnements majeurs corps et
par rapport à ça et bien vous avez une
situation qui fait que en effet vous
devez avoir une prévisibilité du
ministère je suis d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que c'est compliqué et difficile
et qu'il faut pas mettre sur le dos de
blanquaert où tous les malheurs du monde
en revanche il ya malgré tout un sujet
est à mon avis le sujet du ffp2 est un
vrai sujet en tant qu enseignant à
l'université on pourrait se poser
également c'est à dire que quand vous
êtes en contact avec des publics très
différents toute la journée il ya des
risques de contamination qui sont
importants votre employeur comme tout
employeur et bien doit vous assurer une
sécurité minimale le ffp2 en fait partie
et c'est pas lui qui va ruiner l'état
l'éducation nationale oui mais par
exemple un parent d'élève ça représente
quoi rien je suis désolé pour les
syndicats d'ailleurs scellé seul instant
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
mais dire les les fédérations de parents
d'élèves je veux bien mais bon moi je
connais tous les parents que je connais
qui sont vraiment rogne contre 7,7 grève
y en a pas un qui a sa carte
je ne sais quelle organisation
de parents ça fait réagir cette crise
sanitaire au sénat aussi puisque le
sénat débat en ce moment du pass
vaccinale est ce que les débats sont
aussi animés alors dans les débats ont
été beaucoup plus feutrée qu'à
l'assemblée nationale hier on a senti
dès la discussion générale une volonté
chez les républicains et leurs alliés de
rester soudés malgré des points de vue
différents le rapporteur du projet de
loi philippe bas le sait mois après mois
les textes salutaire fracturé un peu
plus la majorité sénatoriale on en est
quand même au 12e projet loi depuis le
début de la pandémie et même si une
majorité de sénateurs républicains
restent favorables aux pass vaccinale il
commence il y en a qui commencent à se
demander quel intérêt il ya encore à
soutenir la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement il fustige une mesure qui
arrive trop tard et qui n'apporte pas de
solutions réelles fin de citation une
fracture qui a empiré depuis les propos
du président emmanuel macron qui
souhaitent emmerder les non vaccinés on
l'a beaucoup répéter certains
républicains aimeraient bien s'opposer à
lui ai voté contre le texte et écouter
notamment muriel jourda qui se faisait
hier à la parole des républicains
opposés au texte
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
beaucoup de choses resteraient à dire
sur par exemple la façon dont ont été
caricaturé ceux qui étaient opposés à la
position du gouvernement parfois par des
propos qu'ils tiennent plus des pires
travers des réseaux sociaux que d'une
méthode digne de gouvernement beaucoup
de choses aussi resterait à dire sur les
tranches philosophie de société qui nous
pousse à faire courir tous les risques
d'un vaccin somme toute assez récent à
nos enfants plutôt que de convaincre les
plus âgés d'aller se faire vacciner
alors hier je sais pas abbas a fait
récemment l
de dire n'importe quoi est ce que les
qu'elle écoute claude malhuret claude
malhuret dit tout le contraire justement
il dit que faut arrêter avec cette
histoire qu on n'essaye pas de
convaincre les médias les professionnels
de santé le gouvernement
tous ceux qui sont en charge des
affaires à leur niveau et bien essaye de
convaincre ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés
alors qu'on arrête avec ça c'est ce sont
les non vaccinés qui jouent pas le jeu
voyons
[Rires]
hier il a essayé de rassembler un peu
tout le monde il a dopé la stratégie de
l'ennemi politique commun en tançant à
plusieurs reprises emmanuel macron je
sais pas si on a cet extrait qui était
quand même assez savoureux
doivent là dedans nous aurons les plus
grandes difficultés pour revenir en
arrière donc une pensons et nous
continuons à penser
hier il a repris les propos d'emmanuel
mâcon qui disait qu'il fallait ne pas
diviser les français apaisé et il a été
un petit peu ironique à la fin en disant
qu' il n'y avait pas meilleur propos que
ce que venait de dire le président de la
république une manière de dire ne nous
divisons pas gardons tous dans la même
direction contre emmanuel macron que je
les fais du côté des centristes alors
séance de calinothérapie hier avec
notamment des propos de loïc hervé le
sénateur centriste qui ne le cache pas
un depuis le début il est contre toute
forme de pas sanitaire de passes
vaccinale il l'a rappelé hier avant même
d'examiner le projet doit il a appris il
a appelé à ne pas l'examiner ce qu'on
refusait une majorité ce quart où vit
une majorité de sénateurs mais là encore
pas d'opposition fratricide un philippe
bas a tenu à lui rappeler qu'il était
d'accord avec lui sur le fond mais qu'il
fallait plutôt débattre de ce texte donc
on le voit pas question de fâcher un
allié si important à quelques mois de
l'élection de l'échéance présidentielle
c'est très politique child
données
si tout se passe bien et les expertises
normalement dans quelques semaines on
devrait être sorti de cette cette phase
la plus difficile la phase la plus
difficile n'est peut-être pas encore
tout à fait d'ailleurs
terminée mais vous vous apercevrez d'une
chose c'est que cette phase très
difficile en termes de contamination
s'accompagne d'une occupation des lits
de réanimation qui est trois fois plus
faible car soit plus faible que au début
de la crise sanitaire c'est ça le seul
critère donc arrêtons quoi bon bah si on
doit effectivement être victimes de ce
virus comme on est victimes parfois de
la grippe mais quand on est en bonne
santé quand on est jeune et bah c'est
pas très grave voilà après celle des
autres qu'il faut protéger effectivement
si beaucoup plus apaisé
c'est politiquement c'est
la droite c'est évidemment très très
politique et c'est évidemment très très
piégeux comme les propos d' emmanuel
macron qui voulait emmerder les français
rafale et non vaccinées étaient
extrêmement piégeux pour la droite en
réalité là vous avez en réalité sheller
au fond un problème qui n'est pas
seulement sur la ligne mais qui est
vraiment un problème de stratégie
politique parce que quand vous regardez
les enquêtes d'opinion oui et que
l'électorat qui est le plus favorable au
passage au pass vaccinale au delà de
l'électorat lrm et d'une partie de
l'électorat social démocrate c'est
l'électorat et l'air est donc l air peut
difficilement dire je suis contre le pas
l'accident -le parce que en réalité ce
serait se mettre en porte à faux avec
ses propres électeurs et ce serait
signal à ses électeurs qu'il faut aller
voter emmanuel macron donc mais il faut
à la fois approuvé le pass vaccinale il
faut pas montrer le peu qu'on ait trop
d'accord avec le président de la
république à quelques mois d'une
élection présidentielle il faut essayer
également parler d'autre chose mais dès
le moment où le président de la
république vous impose ce thème qui
n'est pas clivant avec lui eh bien vous
devez malgré tout le traité donc à
partir de là soit vous essayez de passer
sous
je dirais sous le sous les gouttes et
vous tentez est bien de faire de voter
la chose comme valérie pécresse le veut
sans trop en parler soit vous essayez
justement de trouver des points
d'accrochage de vous opposer sur des
points de détail et d'incarner pour le
coup l'alternative est donc demain
l'alternance mais évidemment par rapport
à votre électorat c'est compliqué c'est
toutes ces difficultés stratégique qui
aujourd'hui créer une vraie polyphonie à
droite alors du coup il y avait comme
unification de la part du sénat à
majorité de droite sur les joues rouges
dans les stades ils veulent la
proportionnelle sur les contrôles
d'identité ils ne veulent pas qu'il
puisse y avoir de contrôle d'identité
suite à un contrôle du pass sanitaires
réservés se passe aux personnes majeures
mettre en oeuvre ce pass vaccinale
uniquement s'il ya plus de dix minutes
spécialisé sur le territoire national
que peut faire la majorité
présidentielle face à ça est ce qu elle
doit accepter ces modifications et si
elle les rejette en bloc est ce qu elle
peut apparaître comme n'écoutant pas
l'opposition ça va être très politique
probablement on va voir une commission
mixte paritaire qu'est ce que la
majorité parlementaire sera en capacité
et aura la volonté de céder il faut voir
parce qu'en réalité au bout du compte
est-ce qu'elle a réellement intérêts
aujourd'hui cette majorité parlementaire
à faire un cadeau au sénat ou est-ce
qu'au contraire et bien dire regardez le
sénat donc entre guillemets la droite
n'a pas adopté le texte donc la droite
et irresponsable en fait elle ne veut
pas du pass vaccinale regarde que c'est
bien là c'est compliqué pour eux mais du
coup vous avez une bataille de symbole
au bout du compte le texte va
probalement pas changé de physionomie
on voit mal le gouvernement est derrière
la majorité faire des concessions
majeures donc soit ça permet de rallier
la droite et donc d'expliquer qu' elle
n'est pas une alternative est donc pas
un facteur d'alternance soi ça permet au
contraire de dire qu' elle n'est pas
responsable qu'elle n'est en réalité pas
pour le pass vaccinale et qu'à partir de
là la seule alternative c'est emmanuel
macron c'est un piège et c'est un piège
qui pour la droite et bien et plutôt
malin
oui c'est un piège effectivement pour la
droite la droite là dessus de 10
beaucoup de deux choses et leur
contraire donc elle est l ai dit lisez
la droite 1 comme sur beaucoup de sujets
d'ailleurs vous dire une chose c'est que
les scores de madame pécresse ne sont
pas très étonnant parce que dans les
intentions de vote parce que ça reflète
finalement une droite qui
éparpillés entre torah ont va dire trois
candidats même siona qui prend encore
candide entre quatre candidats sérieux
entre trois blocs un bloc orléaniste un
bloc gaullo chiraquien et un bloc
nationaliste et cette droite qui étaient
rassemblées par le passé qui est cette
droite qui qui se retrouvait derrière un
seul homme deux hommes qui se faisait là
qui faisait la compétition jusqu'au
dernier moment on va maintenant elle est
éparpillé les éparpiller comme jamais
en position de force parce que la gauche
n'existe plus un point qui peut vraiment
bloqué en commission mixte paritaire
c'est cette suppression des contrôles
d'identité parce qu'en fait la c300 +3
100 sénateurs qui ont voté contre ces
contrôles donc c'est plus seulement la
maj à gratter sénatoriales la droite ça
va des communistes jusqu aux
républicains et là c'est vraiment un
point qu'il ya des sujets même un sujet
potentiellement constitutionnel parce
que même si a priori ce pas la
délégation d'un pouvoir de police c'est
le cas selon le le conseil au vu de la
de l'examen de la loi concernant le pass
sanitaires il ya quand même une vraie
vraie question ce que vous déléguez à
tout un tas de personnel privé le soin
en réalité de contrôler l'identité
d'individus non pas parce qu'il vous
remettent un chèque ce qui en réalité
peut être légitime dès lors qu en effet
oui il ya une transaction qui est
commise mais parce que justement ils
sont réputés pouvoir enfreindre une
règle ça ça pose un vrai problème et on
peut comprendre que du point de vue des
principes également du point de vue
pratique mais le point de vue pratique
et pas si important de ce qu'on a vu que
c'était possible malgré tout dans les
bars dans les cinémas grâce à ces
concepts totalement a priori ça de
bonnes chances de passer au vu de ce qui
s'est passé avec le pass sanitaires mais
il ya quand même un doute qui est
raisonnable
[Musique]